e
so let's go ahead here and we have a
subcommittee today tasked with the
378 378 is Rel to the pbass program
which we have uh performance-based
School accountability system which the
doe uses in terms of looking at
performance
accountability and this bill was
submitted by the department and came to
us from of course from the Senate and
when it was presented to us I think
there were a number of issues raised we
were looking at statutory references too
and saw some the way it once was and
under the annotated versions here so
what I'd like to do for right now uh
there is uh a a a a revised Amendment it
uh which is designed it was supposed to
be just pling draft and not an amendment
with my name on it it would it would be
just a draft for as some of the thoughts
which might go into are looking at this
so what I'd like to do at this time is
open this up to a discussion and invite
uh both uh Caitlyn and Nate up if you're
both involved with this you know since
you working from way back there uh might
okay since uh we last discussed this um
I've had communication with the
department and and in a department with
myself with me as well and I'd like to
just just go drive right break down
through 378 as introduced and 378 as
you're looking on the amendment and we
can go down by Roman 1 2 and go down
through this thing and see where some of
these changes are and whether they
reflect what this committee is uh Desir
us of moving towards so the on the on
the does everybody have the originalist
introduced and the amendment so we can
just put them right beside each other
and try to walk through a little bit we
also had on this one a side by side done
by Jenifer 4 does everybody have that
side by side as well that takes the bill
as introduced and Compares it to current
law so we have several pieces of paper
we can use during our adventure here to
try to figure out where we're going with
this
thing so on on I'm looking at the bill
as introduced right now where it says
Roman one uh under one there is hereby
establish a task force to develop and
review the performance-based school
accountability pbass that will serve to
demonstrate a school is providing etc
etc anybody have a problem with that
because that's current law right
uh no no it's not but is there a problem
do we okay let's jump down to Roman
2 the commissioner in consultation with
the legislative oversight committee
established in RSA 193c colon 8 and
Governor shall appoint no fewer than
nine and no more than 15 members to the
task force which shall consist of this
is where this other Amendment departs
significantly from the language which
us
and
the law on page 570 in your statute
books in small in historical and
statutory notes says at least every four
years the commissioner shall review the
performance-based accountability system
and make recommendation to the
legislative oversight committee the
commissioner May establish a task force
to assist with this review the
commissioner or dis designate shall be
the chairman of the task force and shall
appoint no fewer than and it the
numbers as we have in front of us here
so that's where that older language
was so it's open to discussion now
Caitlyn or Nate you're you're welcome to
just jump in any time because we want to
try to get through this today if we can
um from the committee yes represent
Corell but well okay let's let's start
who's on this committee okay let's first
start with representative cascaden then
who's on the committee and then we'll go
to other members and and then fight
others in yes thank you um I have a
couple uh just a couple points I did the
same thing is go over my notes to see
what would be amended and I see that
some of in in the amendment you gave us
this morning has some of the parts that
I had had put down in my um in my draft
um going back to the statute has there
been a task force
established previous to now that's a
good question for Department there was
previously a task force that was
established but it hasn't been in law
since at least 2020 and it hasn't been
implemented probably since at least 2015
so the the problem or the challenges is
there was the original task force that
um did the P Bass work and then the
department kind of took that to use as
the task force when the Essa act the
every student succeeds Act was passed
and we needed an accountability task
force to oversee our federal legislation
um and we kind of used one in the same
and we still have that task force that's
in place but they focus specifically on
the federal legislation we really do
need a separate one for the state side
of accountability um because it's it
there's too much for one task force to
do we would need full-time people to to
do do it if were to do both so okay that
puts that in perspective anybody else
from the subcommittee per some
dry thank you I I was just going back to
my mental definition of a task force
which is do a task then disband and
looking at this it says the task force
is to develop and review so does that
mean it's in perpetuity this task force
so yeah so we would see it as a a task
force that would um review the
accountability um result each year to
make sure that um when the department is
doing the determinations that they feel
like it is
appropriate um the determinations that
are we eventually put in law will be an
appropriate reflection of the
measurement of an account of of
accountability for an adequate education
um we really do value because because um
right now with our federal
accountability task force it's made up
of practitioners we really do value
their input and so we typically meet
three or four times a year um at least
once before we start the work once after
we start can start the work sometimes
during the work um to make sure that the
work that we're doing is one aligned to
the federal law and then two if the work
that we're doing um needs to or like our
plan needs to be modified as a result of
the of the results of the work that's
done okay follow yes so I guess is that
a task force thing or more like a
commission at that point we call it an
accountability task force um if we want
to update terms um I you know the
department would be happy to do that but
we call it we right now we call it the
accountability perpetuity our current
one does yes okay thank
you representa cascaden again do you
want to keep going down or I mean well
um do you want to wait till you say okay
what about a what about B what about C
okay I I think that what we ought to do
is
just we get the drift to where that
sentences right there let's look at like
uh lines 12 on the amendment 12 down
right through to G okay yep and we do
the do the same thing on on the bill as
introduced and we can also look in the
annotated version as well Mr chair
before we leave to can I just ask why
you took out consultation with the
legislative oversight committee
original it says a commissioner in
consultation with the legislative o
established Governor because later on
the the task force or the department has
to report
to um let's see if I can find it here
yep the end um at the end of the bill
yeah task force should develop
Performance Based
uh scoring system yes yes uh um the task
force shall provide a report of findings
and recommendations for future
legislation for performance
accountability system to the State Board
of Education and the legislative
oversight committee established pursuant
to RSA
um I just marked that down as a note as
a reminder that you know we may want to
to that might be a point of discussion
um it's I've always been a little bit
concerned that the task force which we
have like there's a task force you may
have for social
studies does does the legislature want
to get in and be guiding that prior to a
report being given by the task
force um it's it's uh what's a
I don't know I I think that you the the
oversight committee can get into the
weeds too when perhaps we don't want to
go there um it's just like the executive
committee which we executive task force
the order task force on higher education
which we just completed findings and
recommendations were put together but
the accountability system where they
have to report quarterly back to the
oversight committee regarding progress
being made in the two chancellors are
basically given the leadership
responsibilities for ensuring that work
continues and reports are provided on
where they're going with the alignment
of the two systems I'm more inclined to
say that I'd rather see the task force
have that ability to really delve into
this they're the ones that are going to
have that expertise if we're going to
have commission
members uh that now opens up there would
be members from the senate or the the um
house on there what guarantee do we have
the because a commission has to have
some kind of legislative participation
am I correct on
that yes and do we have that expertise
that's why I'm asking I I just thought I
said in consultation with the oversight
committee instead of the commissioner
just appointing them all it's kind of
like an oversight for who's being
appointed to make sure that there's a
good cross reference of people being
appointed
okay you're saying that so we want to
have
committee well any other thoughts on
that I was going to okay yeah so so I
think I think that's probably why that
language was was in there initially to
uh to try to you know depoliticize the
um the uh formation or the membership of
the um of the task force but I think
there's other ways to do that too um
such as going through you know B through
G and um not making the the nominees uh
subject to to being nominated by the
commissioner but having the nominees uh
being recommended by you know different
groups like the school administrators
Association or School Board Association
or reaching higher other groups like
that and um and you know create a uh uh
create a a a
a basically an informed you know group
that can um that can make the
recommendations for the for for pbass
changes and U you know I think that's a
way where where you know we can we could
leave the the um the accountability and
oversight commission uh for the tail end
like where you've pointed out in in
Roman 9 where it uh it basically
receives the report and reviews the
findings and
recommendations I guess I'm I'm I put it
that way because I'm more familiar with
this occurring differently in the state
I came from in both States Maine and in
Alaska in Alaska the Department of
Education was staffed properly and they
had a Department that was comprised of
people that were doing what Nate is
doing right now and Caitlyn putting
together assessment programs and
accountability programs based upon their
understandings of excuse me test and
measurement understandings of the skills
that are necessary and with what is
needed in the field um we don't have
that here in our department we have are
you it is are you you the
department
yeah yeah so that's it and so so then we
rely on a task force which is up the way
we've done it and that so we put it off
to a group I I you know I just I just
want to ensure that the group somehow
has the expertise that's necessary for
our department in front of us to really
get this job done
properly and I think that's exactly to
to the point I was trying to make uh Mr
chair that um that rather than all of
those nominees coming from uh a singular
uh point that they come from a variety
of of of different uh organizations that
are that are concerned and dedicated to
the Quality outcomes of our
students so Caitlyn it if
um put your your your your your shoes on
as if this is l the way it is right now
in deciding you want to have an
administrator or a teacher whether it be
Elementary or secondary what would you
do in order to find that person would
you automatically pick somebody that you
know or would you also work
collaboratively with some
organization we tend to do I would say a
combination um that's what we do right
now with the current accountability task
force for Essa um where you know if we
have someone that uh leaves that task
force and we need to fill spot um
sometimes we know someone who's already
done a lot of work with our assessment
systems um there's a number of
curriculum uh directors in our districts
there's a few assistant superintendents
and superintendents that we've worked
with that are very knowledgeable about
our current accountability system
oftentimes because they've had schools
within their District or seu that have
been a CSI or TSI school so as a school
leader they're already intimately
familiar with what it means to work with
those schools work with those building
leaders um we often times work with
classroom teachers in the development of
our state assessment systems and so if
we have teachers that have done um item
writing or have sat on bias and
sensitivity committees often times we'll
go to those lists of teacher volunteers
when we're pulling in uh committee
members for this type of work so we tend
to have I would say a a short list or so
of people that you know Caitlyn and I
both know around the state that have
expertise that have worked with our
state assessment assessment systems that
have worked with the accountability
systems um that we tend to go to if we
don't know someone off the top of the
head or we don't have someone immed for
spot that we've worked with often times
we'll reach out to the superintendent
Association we'll reach out to the
principal Association and ask for them
to provide us maybe with a list of two
or three people that might be
interested so it's a bit of a I would
say it's a bit of both so what I'm
trying to do is eliminate the
possibility of the legislature putting
in place something sort of like a pocket
veto uh where you you you have to get
approval from the legislative oversight
to have these members on this particular
task Force well I don't think that would
be appropriate is the legislative
oversight committee where you're going
to feel you're going to get the type of
information you're just expressed you're
seeking are you going to get that from
that group or you going to get it let's
say from Nea or if you're going to get
it from the administrators Association
or the some other group I think those
associations to representative Luna's
Point are you know they sort of know who
in the field
um has the appropriate knowledge and
background to do some of that work we
often rely on their expertise for
identifying individuals um I think the
the checks and balances that exist in
here is the fact that any recommendation
has to come to the legislative oversight
committee from this task force so we
can't do the accountability system
without their recommendations becoming
Law And so there's almost two steps in
there that I see that it has to come to
the legislative oversight committee and
be recommended and then from there it
would have to come to both this group
and Senate education to actually become
you know future law so there's two
points I think where the the legislature
itself is ultimately the Arbiter of what
becomes the next pbass system the
committee can't recommend a system and
then move forward and Implement that
right so further
discussion we got to get this thing
worked out yeah I think I think there
there is my concern is that there's a
difference
between consultation and
Reporting and
so it's one thing to receive a report
and then react to the
report there's
another activity that takes place prior
to the report that's developed by the
committee and that's why I think back to
what representative luno said said is to
ensure that there is a and and rep
representative Cornell that there is a
balance on there and I think that's why
the the consultation is important
clearly the legislative oversight
committee is not going to have the same
expertise as those who work with it on a
daily basis which Nate you referred to
but I think that there is a concern and
I'm not sure how to resolve it to ensure
that the people who are on
that have some sense of balance before
they start their work and so that I
guess that's the concern that I would
have too and I do know that in the past
anyway when we created the evaluation
system which was a lengthy process that
was done several years ago The Advocate
groups were clearly engaged in that at
the GetGo and not as just receiving a
report to say and getting feedback on it
so I think somewhere in
between um that there that's that would
be my concern is how do you make sure
that the PE Personnel that are there do
in fact rep have a broad sense of
constituency representation to help
develop it that's my
concern is it necessarily represent Myer
a a
broad uh understanding of
constituency representation or is it to
ensure that folks have a a clear
understanding of performance-based
accountability yes so we want yes they
both yes yes yes
okay I'm saying is that I think you can
have
because we can have both because I think
there are persons and I'm not saying
that an advocate group like a
superintend Association for example that
they dominate the group but that there
is a voice that they have a voice
in the
group um balanced by those who may be
directly more directly involved on a
day-to-day basis that's all I'm saying
so I'm not saying that I've said what
I've
said repon luno yeah I think what
representative Myer talks about is is
right on I think it's consistent with
what Dr Green and and Miss Davis were
were we talking about uh as well uh as
and as long as we're we're
um um bringing in the involvement of
multiple org superintendent Association
principal Association School Board
Association um you know as Dr Green has
has suggested happens on you know you
know in the background not by
legislative action but uh but in the
background when it comes to making
current uh recommendations but but
actually I've got a a question to to Dr
Green if I might because you you brought
up TSI and CSI and um and and last time
we met I think we talked about whether
this um whether pbass applies to Charter
Schools and um and I think the answer
was no it doesn't apply to I think
that's what the answer was and I was
wondering how if you could sort of talk
about that a little bit and talk about
how how
pbass determines TSI and CSI and what
that all means so that
so right now there there's some
confusion with the existing system be
because of how pbass kind of refers back
to the federal law
so right now um we have Federal
accountability which is CSI TSI schools
all of that that applies only to Title
One schools now a charter school may be
a title one school as and in the most
case is because charter schools are
eligible for title One funds and so any
school that's receiving Title One funds
would be categorized for the purpose of
federal
accountability
um
now then the thing that's then confusing
is so that's not so we have Federal
accountability it doesn't apply to all
schools and there are a fair number of
schools specifically high schools in the
state that are not Title One schools so
they're not um not required to
participate in the federal
accountability system on the state side
of things um um so State accountability
should apply to all scho all public
schools um and right now it does it
apply sorry all public district schools
that's who pbass currently applies to
but it doesn't apply to Charter Schools
so with the two systems we could have a
CSI school that is a federal CSI school
but not categorized for this purpose of
State accountability and then we could
have a state CSI school that is a CSI
school for State accountability but not
for federal accountabil ility and that's
kind of one of the main reasons that we
would like to see a segregation of the
two different systems because they have
very different accountability
requirements and so using the same
terminology is not really helpful for
the people that are being that are um
involved in that system and so we would
really like we would like to get a when
we eventually come up with you know a
state accountability system as a result
of this task force hope to God we would
not use the word CSI and TSI because it'
be way too confusing will have a
different you know schools in need of
improvement or um I think there was
maybe talk one of the last time was had
maybe another um some additional
amendments from it was maybe even from
1583 that was different different
terminology and I think if you we're
doing State accountability we really do
want State account um we really want to
just kind of to separate the two now um
as far as the charter schools there is
um a requirement for accountability in
the state Charter School law but the
state accountability system as in ibass
and pbass do not currently apply to
Charter Schools which means for State
purposes we are not running those
calculations but we are then running the
pbass calculation which is a tied to the
federal accountability for charter
school so it's it's very confusing um is
there Charter Schools would um when
we're talking about overall
accountability and remember we have to
do ibass and pbass ibass is not
something that is necessarily
um applicable to Charter Schools because
they're not required to comply with the
the minimum standards so we take that
outside of it but could we potentially
come up with a pbass system that could
also apply for charter schools because
remember it's based on performance it's
based on data we could we could do that
um and that is something that this task
force could certainly talk about but
that would be a change into the
law so go ahead so so would that would
that be something that and we're not
down to it quite yet but I think we're
getting close down in Roman 3 and I'm
looking at representative lad's draft
for discussion but this is the duties of
the task force and that could be
considering
um everything that you just talked about
here including maybe new terms coming
from from the state uh accountability
you could you could add that um but if
you wanted to have if you wanted to
require it for Charter Schools there's a
different section in RSA 193e that you
would have to make it applicable to
Charter Schools as well because because
we' have to go in and just and modify
that section as well okay but but this
task force could certainly study the
system and see if it's something that
could be applicable to Charter Schools
um and maybe if you want them to keep in
mind it specifically design a system
that could work for Charter Schools too
it sounds like that might be something
this committee could do so Caitlyn what
would happen if we put in uh something
under Roman three saying uh the pbas
system will be applicable to Charter
Schools so what would happen so what we
would do is we would run the same
determinations for charter schools that
we are for public schools I think one of
our one of the challenges sometimes with
Charter Schools is specifically size of
schools um and so uh making sure that we
would have enough data but the other
thing and this is um where the the
federal accountability system sometimes
fails Charter Schools or any sort of
alternative schools is we do have a fair
number of charter schools that are
specifically um set up to to support at
risk determination or at risk um
populations um and so um we have a
number of charter schools right now that
are being categorized as CSI schools
just because of the nature of their
population that's applying to them or
that they're helping um and so there is
no carve out for that federal law it's
something that we have specifically
reached out to the US Department of
Education about and so we would want to
talk about that and the impacts on those
schools that are for at risk populations
but we should have that same sort of
things for all public schools
realistically too so if a school
district wanted to do a specific set up
a school that was specifically
designated to help atrisk populations we
don't want to necessarily automatically
designate them right now either and
that's that is the challenge with the
federal system so we would want to talk
about how that would impact the the
charter schools that are those at risk
schools versus your traditional regular
charter school that is just set up to um
enroll New Hampshire resident children
so so not not to get too far ahead of
ourselves or the task force um are are
um are
Charters did did are Charters held to
the same adequate education minimum
standards that um that public school
districts are no so charter schools are
held to a different accountability
system that exists in RSA 194b and
there's a different uh funding scheme
set up for Charter Schools as well later
on in the statute so when you look at
193 E3 it's specific to the adequate
education funding that goes to public
schools and it's not applicable to
Charter Schools because Charter Schools
don't receive that stream of funding so
there is accountability but the
accountability is in a different statute
and it's not this statute right right
and and is the is the accountability
from a um from
a let's let's call it a pbass standard
uh would would that be would that by
definition have to be different for a
charter than a public um school because
the funding is different the standards
are different the requirements are
different the expectations you would
wants are different yeah so if we were
to create something in here that was
applicable to Charter Schools we would
want to also look at 194b to make sure
that the two accountability systems did
not end up in contradiction with
themselves where charter schools are now
being held to two um competing systems
right so you'd have to evaluate both of
those in the light of each other um the
current accountability system for
Charters is specific to the Charter
itself it requires every Charter School
to identify in the charter approved by
the state board their mission vision and
goals and the standards for which they
want to be held to so that if a charter
school is you know their mission isic
specific to uh supporting high school
students at risk of Dropout the metrics
by which they're measuring themselves
are things like getting kids through
various completion programs whether it's
the highet uh alternative diploma
programs getting kids to a regular high
school diploma but maybe doing it in
five years or six years as opposed to
your traditional four-year path when we
overlay things like a four-year
graduation requirement on those schools
it's a metric they'll never meet because
they may have a third of their
population that's coming in in their
fifth year and so they can't graduate in
four years because that ship is already
sailed for those students so you for
that particular school and their unique
Mission you would want an accountability
system that matches the mission of the
school so that's the current
accountability system it's supposed to
be tied to each individual Charter okay
okay thank thanks that's a really good
explanation I would point out to it's
it's not necessarily unique to Charters
either we have alternative programs in
public school districts that also
struggle to meet current accountability
systems a really good example that is
Bud Carlson Academy and rochest
um has a very similar Mission the
majority of their students work through
bud Carlson Academy in addition to
working with an adult ed high school or
a highet program and so many of those
students can't meet the current
accountability system that we have set
up so Bud Carlson will always be a CSI
school right but they're doing really
amazing things for the students that are
coming through that school it's just
that the system is set up to measure
things that those students are not going
to be able to achieve because of the
point that they're at in their
educational careers so so when and if I
might so I i' I've seen you know bud
Carlson um Academy on the CSI list you
know you know and um and this is helping
explain that um for me so that is part
of the Rochester school district it is
yeah so many of those students you know
for one reason or another were not able
to be successful in the traditional
curriculum within the Rochester school
system and so they attend Bud Carlson
which does a lot more support around
flexible schedules it allows students
maybe who need to work during the day to
then attend a highet program in the
afternoon or at night um I want to say
they have maybe somewhere between 48 and
50 students so it's not a large program
um but when we look at things like State
assessment requirements most of the
students are seniors or their fifth year
seniors or their sixth year seniors so
many of them aren't required to take the
SAT because that's required in 11th
grade so there's not a lot of assessment
evidence we can use um I think we only
generally have maybe three or four
students that take the SAT out of about
the 40 or 50 students that attend so
it's difficult to get achievement data
to then use as part of the
accountability system um so for
alternative programs like that our
current accountability system just isn't
set up to measure them effectively right
so so just just just based on what what
I just learned on on this thing just
from this conversation here um with with
B Bud Carlson Academy you know you know
perennially on the on the CSI list that
does not mean Bud Carson um uh Academy
is
failing it failing in its Mission or
failing its students or failing in
general and it doesn't mean that the
Rochester school district is failing in
its Mission we failing in general either
right I would argue that they're
actually doing really amazing things for
those students because by having the
academy in the first place they're
keeping students in some type of program
as opposed to those students just ending
up on the Dropout list right um and
there are a number of other districts
that have programs similar program up in
Woodsville Newport has a program um NASA
has a program um this is an example
where the message doesn't correspond
with with really what's happening corre
and and that's partly why we need to
look at the accountability system as a
whole because we need to say like what
are these different types that we can
really design a system to help and
support those system is this a it's an
important topic where just talking about
here is that something that that you
believe given the nature what the task
force has to do you're not we would be
expanding it to see the applicability of
pbass to certain Charter Schools
certainly King Street School I I think
would have a difficult time with some of
this um it's a small school like we've
been just talking about within
sau23 um and they I think two pro so
King Street and French Pond and French
ponds the other ones yeah exactly it's a
it's an alternative program sort of
outside your traditional curriculum
that's still serving those students yeah
are there scores meshed in with SE would
the the co-op or they they will be now
going forward initially they had been
separate alternative um schools they've
recently now uh kind of brought those
schools back in under the uh Woodsville
High School um and the middle school
there yeah so the the results going
forward will be reported uh as part of
the overall Woodsville scores um
previously they been classified sort of
oddly in our database um and so their
scores weren't actually being reported
um anywhere um they weren't part of
Woodsville and they weren't they were
popping up um sort of oddly as private
schools well certainly there their goals
their objectives are more aligned IEP
type orientation than they are on that
and I I I don't know if putting under
that big umbrella of the high school in
Woodsville is the appropriate thing to
and these are the sort of things we
would really like to have conversations
with the task force um this is well
maybe it's something we can add on as a
duty to the task force yeah yeah yeah I
I made a note too on the bottom of the
page here let's go back up to the top
here though we're we were dealing with
consultation consultation with what the
the legislative oversight and the
governor what's the governor going to do
in terms of helping to provide
membership and and what really is the
legisl it's consult with some of the
professional organizations we have
within our
state and so maybe we need to word it as
such yeah and and more than consultation
I I you know this
is consultation sort of doesn't doesn't
mean very much like yeah we talked about
it but but I I would suggest that that
um that these organizations actually
then you're going to have to figure out
which organization's going to do the
nomin it's going to be AF Nea uh
reaching higher uh for for example
there's two down on um down an F there's
there's uh two two teachers yeah one by
Nea one by AF um there's I think five or
six uh where is it in B there's six uh
administrat ERS they can all be
nominated by the um uh
SAA uh there's one School Board member
by Schoolboard
Association principes yep uh there's
dry hi go ahead before we go a little
bit further I just want to ask in D in
the original bill it's kind of a catch
off you know educational experts parents
uh members of a public interest group
you know interested in education and
that doesn't make the jump to the
amendment like there's no parents no
public groups or anything is that
intentional well in the amendment it
says GE other educational experts who's
understanding performance-based
accountability expertise would
be you know a benefit to that that task
force that could be apparent but you see
if what you want to do is are you going
to put a person on a group like that
just because they're a parent or are you
going to also be looking to see what
this person can bring it's going to be
between nine and 15 people and they're
all going to have to have some
understanding what how do we measure
Performance
Based okay so follow up I'm just the way
um you're describing somebody nominating
it how would a parent get nominated at
that point
first question is why why the parent
yeah I I well I'm just saying this is
what's already in the bill and I just
wondered if we we're bringing that
forward at all well you could you assume
that at least one of these people that
are from the
other organizations is a parent I would
assume somewhere along the way there's
going to be a parent in there I mean I I
have five kids in the public school
system so I certainly don't mind also
representing a parent but I did have a
long discussion with I I can't remember
was Nate or or Caitlyn on this or not
long but a discussion saying what are
some of the skill sets that we want
these individuals to have so we come out
of here with something that's meaningful
and relevant and yes you know we
performance is always not measured by a
test although we do say something
objective elsewhere in statute but
there's other ways of doing that I think
we can get that from the classroom
teachers we can get that from everybody
else here here but it's the skill set
that they bring forward I was I was
going to comment on that because I think
even though you're talking about the
advocate groups making these
recommendations it seems to me that
there ought to be some standard with
which that individual comes from so it's
not just not just any classroom teacher
but it's would be a classroom teacher
that's actually done the assessments
been involved in it maybe even done some
gradual work in it so that it would seem
to me that there could be uh some some
qualifying language for the
recommendations that would come forward
see that's why I I don't mean to hog the
conversation that like an F we're
talking about the teachers that are
familiar with performance spacee other
Educators in G that you know you know it
says the same thing uh who who's
understanding of Performance Based so
that would go into you know I would say
the you know whether it's something's
reliable or valid or Etc in the in the
test and measurement domain as well I
think it's important to remember these
are very Heavy D data driven
conversations and meetings and a very
unique person would be in it's it
already takes a very unique person to be
interested in doing this work to begin
with because of the type of work it is
and so it is important that we have
somebody with the right skill set um I'm
wondering if um maybe instead of
assigning a parent to this area um or
even talking about some of the other um
constituents maybe if we have a place
where the task force would hold like a
listening session or a couple type
things like that to really gauge that
Community input because this is such an
important measurement but then the
day-to-day parts of this conversation
really are um in the hands of the
experts that are used to dealing with
the Education data and I mean to have
somebody else's point I'm not sure
representative Miler um even not every
single superintendent in this seat is
going to be appropriate for this role
because different superintendent have
very different skill sets or different
teachers or whatnot and and that's
something that we're really going to
want to measure before we put people um
on this task force um and it's that's
going to be very important to Department
like we're going to we're going to need
to come up with some sort of process to
make sure that people have the the
skills and the time to commit to this
and understand because this is
it's a lot of work the Department's
going to be expecting from these
individuals yeah you know if your task
force is doing their job the committee
we were on Dave representative luno that
the task for the executive order we took
time to listen to students we took time
to gather from the professors we did a
big we took time to do that with
numerous folks that had been in the
business of chaning and all that and
with that we got good input yeah that's
important so the hearing process should
involve gathering information as you say
k through
the so would you I mean maybe should we
write that in into this or I just made a
note to add in underneath uh Roman
three some reference to the hearing
process to gather information from the
field and all those that are involved
and I we did do that when we developed
the Essa plan we did Statewide listening
tours with that um we went to a fair
number of schools across the state um at
night so parents could come in and and
provide input and maybe we drag some of
that language for that and put it in
here yeah I yeah represent chair lad I
think that's a that's a really good
observation here because I think that
task force ran pretty well and uh and I
think it particularly ran well with um
with with the um with the Department you
know serving as uh you know as sort of
chief of staff and and support for that
for that task force with director
applebe um as its chair and and um and
uh uh Dr um Nick what's Nick last marks
Nick marks and he was exceptional yeah U
and and so so two individuals that I
think are are conspicuously absent from
this list are um are both of you um and
and maybe that's something that we want
to consider is is a task force that that
is really I would gather you know I
would hope that the commissioner or
design and we're looking at the design
right in front of us um one of you
probably
Nate so to some extent that we expect
this task force to be um oversight to
the department and so it's challenging
when the department is actually a voting
member and that's partially why we wrote
in the department personnel shall advise
facilitate and provide Tech technical
support but we're really looking for the
experts that the the external people
that are working with the kids and and
implementing the assessments and
collecting the data and doing all that
to really advise how it's going to work
in the field and so you know if if a you
know the task force comes up with some
sort of recommendation that then
Department go well we can't Implement
that because we don't have a way of
collecting that data or you know X Y and
Z we would be part of that conversation
we would be obviously at every single
meeting but we're really looking for the
experts to advise us on
this per pen no I have a little bit of a
different question it has to do with how
the um task force is comprised so it's
on line 10 it says no fewer than nine
and no more than 15 members and when you
count up lines a through C right there
that's nine already and then by the time
you get down to line F you're at 13 so
how where where's the wiggle room in the
allotment of the makeup of the commit
yeah that would come under the other
experts under under G and the reason for
that is that uh I included in here an
elementary teacher and a secondary
teacher uh so that we can get from the
field what has been going on and how
what's our perceptions and insights in
terms of performance-based assess
accountability so it it narrows it down
there's more identified and so you don't
have two left over I saw that also but
uh it's going to be difficult trying to
find real good people to be on this task
force this it seems like the minimum is
really 13 like no fewer than 13 and no
more than 15 Because by the time you get
down to line G you only have two
positions
left
govern close to that number I don't have
it in front of me today but I know that
for example when we setting up some of
our boards we have up to it's always an
odd number it goes up to 9 to 15 I
believe for
co-ops so it's a it's a common number we
use 15 for number of things uh I'm not
questioning the number I'm just
questioning the minimum
yeah
good at least should be consistent
with with the the listed require
MERS I just and another thing to
remember is like there's a lot of
superintendents that also hold a
principal certificate that also hold
teaching certificate so I mean some
people could count as more than once too
so we we've got a there there is some
but further discussion we got to go back
up now let's get this thing on Roman two
did we resolve the consultation issue or
not I heard we had not got there yet
yeah so I'm I'm I'm in favor of using
using language nominated by and and and
having the groups and you you know what
I I I know there's an infinite number of
groups but but just looking at the the
groups that that regularly um come to
207 and um and attend hearings uh whe
whether it's um School Board Association
or or School administrators Association
uh reaching higher we've got uh the New
Hampshire um um special Educators um is
it s special
education
administrators SAA so so Jan B on uh and
and and and then you know when it comes
to G we also have a lot of you know very
interested you know uh people that may
take have different views um on things
you know from you know Bonnie Dunham
um well you also people that are doing
the teaching of this at PSU and
Kean right they're they're very good in
this area of U they have classes on it
yeah so I I I think having having you
know people that that have spent a lot
of time in this committee show
a a vested interest in um in the work
the state does in for on educational
standards and and student outcomes um
having them make
nominations uh the the commissioner
shall appoint based on the those
nominations and uh and so I think much
of the language could could stay but but
that each of the ones a
through a through F or a through G have
um nominated
by you know New Hampshire you know I'm
just looking at D New Hampshire
nominated by New Hampshire Schoolboard
Association I actually disagree with
that because I think it would be um in
the purview of the commissioner to reach
out to those organizations to ask for
nominations I'm not necessarily certain
that that would have to be in
statute and and I certainly would
disagree with listing specific
organizations in statute
oh it was in statute on the on the task
force not by organizations but by
different um uh on the governor's task
force based on on different different
roles and um and you
know given the given the the um you know
the sort of the you know the nature of
today's politics I I think having having
language that that more mirrors how the
um how the governor's task force was
established uh would uh would result not
only in I think more um um uh you know
work that that is representative of the
broad interests of of granite Staters
but um but but also something that that
is going to provide uh a good um a good
work product that um that when it when
it comes to the
oversight uh assessment and oversight um
uh committee down in the bottom of page
two uh is going to be something that
that that has recommendations that can
be um can be turned into into statute
which I think is the whole you know
this is there a term for serving on this
I mean are we asking them to commit the
Tass is there a is there a term for the
length of a person that's on this task
force how long do you see this task
force Caitlyn or Nate continuing yeah it
may continue because there is a process
which we have laid out there should
always be an oversight task force for
the accountability for an adequate
education it will be something that be
extremely helpful for the Department as
we you make changes and recommendations
um as far as terms we don't have terms
on our EX task force it's typically a
superintendent retires and so we need or
or moves to a role where they you know
feel like they can't commit the amount
of time needed to it um because we like
the consistency a lot of times uh it's
really helpful to have you know the
people that have been on the federal
accountability task force for five six
years now are probably some of the most
helpful because they remember why
certain things were written into the the
plan and whatnot um but I mean having
terms could be beneficial too we would
want them staggered so we're not looking
for new task force all at once and
things like that I that I mean that
might be something that could be figured
out over time and there will be probably
natural attrition over time that we
law I guess I'm asking this question is
is if we're looking to organizations
we're kind of assigning a letter to
different organizations and I just
wonder if we want to commit ourselves to
that you know I
I I still think we need some latitude on
this that we want to have the very best
people on here we can get regardless of
where they come from uh we're talking
about our accountability system for
education
and it's important that these people
coming on have that great skill set it's
not like the public school
infrastructure commission where we have
identified you will have Homeland
Security director so the director leaves
a new director but the next director is
on it
automatically um the members from the
senate in the house are appointed each
year each by Anum by the president or
the speaker we we have a rotation but
it's not built into
law uh right but Mr chair on on you know
like you said you you're just talking
about the oversite um committee right
the members appointed by the president I
was talking about the public school
infrastructure Commission the
oversight's very similar very very
similar to that but um but th those
those appointments are also based on um
the um the the you know the composition
of the the two the two Chambers the
house and the house and the Senate and
the way this is currently drafted here
all of the appointments of something
that affects um 165,000 students um you
know more if you include charters um you
know Statewide all of the nomination all
the all of the appointments would come
from uh a single Source uh and um and I
I think given the given the broad uh
impact that that this has that that
having um you know having multiple
organizations involved in in uh making
those Rec making those nominations the
commissioner could certainly select from
from those I'm not you know I I I think
the structure of this that you know
provides for that uh is uh is real
important and and we've seen certainly
multiple uh you
know a number of organizations
represented here over the 120ish bills
we've had uh even this year Alone um
that uh that have shown a vested
interest in U in in student outcomes and
and may have different approaches to it
now that's fine but I think having a
having a a task force that that is uh
composed of people who are vested and
skilled uh that can uh that can arrive
at an out you know Rec findings and
recommendations that you with with with
with Dr Green and Miss Davis's support I
think it's really important here
um okay
let if you go down to line 13 where six
or more individuals will hold a current
naire certification superintendent
assistant superintendent or curriculum
administrator so which organizations
would the commissioner contact the State
School administrators Association uh
Elementary principals Association uh
secondary admin the for for for for B
and and but would the department have a
better handle
on which superintendant really have been
involved with curriculum development and
test and measurement whereas there's
some superintendants might be good uh
CEOs from the perspective of finances
but not on the other side of the coin
they rely upon staff interworking within
that administrative group maybe like a
Manchester which has the support staff
around so so yeah I and and I think
nobody would have a better sense of that
when it comes to to uh School District
leadership than um than um uh you know
Fu maybe maybe I you know because that
changes too that does change you know if
you you could go back to the leadership
we once had there would they have yeah
well Dr Joyce yes I I have a lot of
faith in in in Mark but uh
there I I I don't know Nate do you have
anything to say on that I think
regardless of whether it's written into
statute or not the the work that we do
with accountability and assessment can't
be done without the support and
assistance of the organizations we
regularly reach out to them um on our
current threeyear Cycles we identify
about 90 schools around the state I'm
the one that calls each of those School
principles to talk them through their
data to let them know what the
determination was to let them know what
it's going to look like for the next you
know year to two years to three years
for their school so you know I I think
there's a lot of different ways we could
write this in here regardless we're
going to be working with those
associations I think whether it's in
statute or not because just to do the
work itself we're working with all the
superintendents in the state We're
working directly with the building
principles we have a lot of sort of
active stakeholder groups that we reach
out to when we're considering changing
internal policies or we're looking at uh
you know taking different parts of our
state Assessments in different
directions in order to keep up with
current instructional Trends and you
know what's happening as we move towards
things like you know computer science
and Ai and you know all the different
things that are you know starting to
appear in classrooms that are you know
new for teachers and new for students so
I think it's already an integral part of
the system we have in in place now um
and I think to Caitlyn's Point too there
are a lot of superintendents in the
state many of them have different
backgrounds U many of them have
different interests that they're
interested in whether it's curriculum
instruction whether it's assessment
whether it's you know fiscal policy
within their Community um and we tend to
work really closely with the group of
superintendents and principles who have
a really strong understanding of
assessment and account accountability um
so I I I would just throw it out there
that I think we're we're currently doing
that I think we work a lot with those
associations now even in the work that
we're doing than thank thanks thanks
very much um I'm I'm I'm satisfied with
you Nate in working with these folks out
in the field you could probably come up
with a list of those people which have
the expertise in this area that really
show up when you're talking with them on
the horn or whatever they are probably
able to go down into the weeds and ask
the type of questions which need to be
asked rather than somebody say yes I'll
do it just send me the send me the form
uh and and this is this is something we
very frequently do like we have we have
a question in the office like all right
which superintendent should we consult
and we we have our go-to that we know
about that we like be able to answer
that on the spot or or whatnot um one
thing we also just need to be make sure
we're careful of too is just time and
consideration how much you know people
can dedicate to this just because a
superintendent has the knowledge doesn't
mean they have the time or capacity
given whatever challenges they're
currently experiencing in the school
district like a principal that's from a
school that's building a school might
not be able to participate in this task
force right now even though they have a
great expertise they need to put their
resources on that so things like that
that's we're we're constantly
considering that we're constantly
working with that we are in consultation
with nhsa very regularly um and school
boards Association and and working
through those committees make or those
um those groups make it easier for us do
our job
so so we'll rewrite Roman 2 there on
line
10 to try to integrate some of our
discussion which we've had here could
you help us do that Nate or or Caitlyn
or do you want us to sit down as
legislators to write in consultation or
in with nomination from or
whatever yeah I I think you could do it
in relatively General language kind of
gets to the the heart of what we're
talking about here that's you know in
consultation with stakeholder groups and
associations in the state that are
involved with assessment and
accountability work that's good to me
without identifying you know the
specific groups yeah how much of a time
commitment do you think this
involves or what was that well how much
time do you think it will involve how
just generally how long how much time
say in the I mean it probably yeah a
fair amount um and I heard you just say
once a month I would say actually
probably more frequently than once a
month I could see like doing two two-day
meetings especially in the beginning
when we're really trying to get the work
and the organization and what not
planned uh it makes sense to do it more
frequently too um backtack days just so
people are not forgetting each month um
but I would say yeah in the first year
probably at least two days a
month this is a huge job uh we had a
person up in the district I was in that
that was a sole job PhD and also was
teaching at the University of Alaska
Anchorage on this topic and was
extremely knowledgeable and spent
fulltime doing
this and we're asking now to be done
through a task force here um so it's
going to be this is
why when when Steve applebe chaired that
committee with his assistant there we
always had the minutes went out the the
records were kept squared away we had
support we request information they made
the contacts to get the people in from
the field it wasn't all on the
chair and I that's you know on every
even like CTE Jeff beard does our
work um
yes
yeah
yes so so with that said what is the
meaning of 2A 2A the commissioner
designate who shall S no no I'm talking
down I'm talking down excuse me down at
uh
927 927 personal shall advise
facilitate is that what we're talking
about right so we we're going to be a
part of the task force but we're not
saying that we're voting memb we need to
be there we need to attend all of the
meetings we're going to facilitate the
meetings we're going to call the
meetings do the Mee minutes call the
meeting get the resources there correct
that's how you envision that two way
okay thank you and I I think too when
we're talking about pulling in outside
groups there's you know New Hampshire is
actually really lucky and that there are
a lot of national assessment experts and
organizations that call New Hampshire
home um several large National
assessment companies um Center for
assessment which has done a lot of work
with the Department um that's
essentially built account systems for
the state of Utah for Wyoming um they're
currently working directly with Hawaii
so we have a lot of really good
expertise here that while necessarily
wouldn't be you know a specific member
on the task force the department would
be able to pull them in based off of
what's going on in the current
discussions when are the meetings you
know this group over here has this
expertise we got measured progress now
cogy up in the SE Coast Area um so I I
also see that as part of what the
department will be able to do because we
have those connections with various
assessment and accountability experts in
the state that can come in as needed and
advise the task
force now are we good with that aine 12
the commissioner designate that they
will be that individual will be a member
where I read this because it says uh
shall consist of the commissioner or
designate who
shall uh select the chairman or or is
the the chairman going to be elected by
the at at the first
meeting which often times turns back to
be somebody that's you know in charg and
has the resources to act as a chair um
yeah I I I think that's challenging for
the Department where we really expect it
to be oversight and then we're putting
the department on it um I think
obviously two meetings ago we had robust
conversations of how does the um
chairperson get elected and I would
imagine that is your response to doing
that but I I don't know that you want
the department to be on the actual
committee so much as just having the
force represent cascaden um just add to
the discussion I had in my notes also
that we talked about the task force
should be elected once it is put
together I didn't perceive the dep
Department of Ed would be part of that
nine to 15 member
group um let me see that that we that
the task force once it was put together
would elect a chair and it wouldn't be
somebody from the Department of Ed
because because of what their role is
didn't know if it would add value to add
current employee or public school
experience anywhere or even public in
the school board member because it's
very technical work
M um and then the last thing I mean I
had a lot of what you had in your
Amendment um
I don't know I've never worked with a
curriculum director in my district and a
lot of districts don't have that
position does that matter here um as
long as there's one on the committee
that represents the state is that what
there so yeah so I think the the
curriculum instructors that we work with
are excellent throughout the state but
you're right not every district has them
and in many districts a superintendent
or assistant superintendent really
serves that role and so that's kind of
why in that line six we had the
superintendent assistant superintendent
or sorry line 13 um be so superintendent
assistant superintendent or curriculum
administrator now the confusing thing is
is though also now we have it down
online 18 um so that's almost like two
of of those folks but they are a very
important indiv the school districts
that have them that's the people that
are doing the majority of this work in
in those school districts that's why we
okay so you saying Kaylin you would take
out line 12 the commissioner designate
who shall select the chairman of the
task force to to keep that out I think
that should actually be um down on line
27 if we're wanting the commissioner um
to select the chairman because I I think
that was in response to we had these
conversations about how do we get a
chairman so I think that really actually
belongs down in 2A so the department
shall advise blah blah blah and then it
say the commissioner shall select the
the um chairman if that's how you wanted
to be or as representative cascaden just
said or have the committee the task
force elected the task force could elect
one that was definitely a big question
that came up last time somebody's going
to have to call the first meeting right
the commission could do that and I would
think the commissioner would do that
call the first meeting and then at that
first meeting then you go through your
electing duties put in
there that's very typical yeah okay y
that would make sense okay the
commissioner designate yeah call the
first meeting
Y and chair elected it's usually when
when it's and if he's not going to be a
member of it the commissioner does the
calling he did remember the Civics book
textbook stuff that was called by the
commissioner and and then uh then we
elected right a chair ltin yeah right
right and that's with most of them yeah
the case in the case of the higher ed
task force uh it was the commissioner's
design who um who called the meeting and
and shared the uh and voted and voted
and voted well you know but but also
important thing I think for this task
force too um is that it it was for the
hirate task force we worked to consensus
yeah I mean isn't that how this this is
a work to consensus St sure is yeah yeah
yeah so okay so the commissioner will
not be a member or destiny will not be a
member we know call the
meeting and and and then they will and
start the meeting first meeting out and
then elect the chair there and then back
then the technical support comes in to
assist
okay well would give you instead of two
I'd give you
three from Modern math is correct here
okay
which gives you
know that's good because maybe you get
more experts invol I don't know you
might yeah we might get a teacher yeah
okay
um so that takes us down so we'll take
the commission drop it down in the line
27 where it's 2A and write all that
language in there Y and then we'll have
Nate help us write some language up top
on line 10
or yeah 10 11 there yep so that's good
and then on item three there Roman three
the task force shall the following
duties um we wanted something in there
like investigate and make
recommendations regarding uh the
applicability of the PB pbas program
PBB as yeah program applicability
Charter
wayil yeah leave it there so they can
deal with that which they probably
should touch
on and and also and also and also um um
alternative schol yeah alternative
schools that's a regular ongoing
discussion that we have currently within
my office um with my staff is you know
the alternative programs charter schools
so I think that conversation could very
easily feed into to this task force as
well okay so we can put that in there um
so would it be public Charters and
public public Alternatives or does it
matter is that what you're thinking I
think separate they're very very similar
I think you would want to look at at
both because you'd want to have some
kind of carve out that allows for
flexibility for schools that have
alternative models which includes public
alternative schools and Charter Schools
yep is alternative schools the
appropriate term it it's that's the term
in statute yep that's okay yeah I think
people understand that and and then also
I think include in Roman 3 um
uh public comment and uh do we have
opportunities for public comment set up
by the task force langage for that but
with is it anywhere in here you know
Consulting with with other other you
know e experts and and uh and
stakeholders uh you know like what we
talked about with the with the
governor's task force and high where
we does it need to be in statute or the
task force just say well let's reach out
to so and so they I'm not saying
reaching out to specific people but but
that that uh because I think we have had
this in commissions and other Tas task
forces before that that you you um um
uh we we did and you're talking hyad we
did reach out to
some of the to Nei and some of the other
organizations and and we found out that
there have been three attempts for a
merger throughout the country and all
three have failed um and and and that
was one of the reports which we saw
right I think I think what
representative luno is saying is that
just that experts will be made available
to the task force just a general
statement general statement reach out to
consult with with with others you don't
even need to call experts but consult
with others outside you know yeah
outside entities or something like
that yeah you education commission stage
all these other things yeah
yeah you probably do you need
it it's it's likely something we would
do anyway so I don't think it needs to
be written in somebody on Tas they're
going to do this research and research
means Chas going out yeah there's a
National Association of alternative
schools um that focuses a lot of um
their effort on this there is not a
chapter in New Hampshire there are a
couple of alternative schools in New
Hampshire that have looked to see what
it would take to create a chapter of
that Association here in the state so
that could be a national expert group
that we could reach out to um we have
some local uh Charter School groups the
New Hampshire Charter School Alliance um
is one that we could reach out to that
sort of represents charter schools
within New Hampshire so there are groups
that we would likely reach out to okay
let's let's move down so we can add
something in there where where the
research it's kind of a given there
going to be doing that but uh Roman
four uh Department May provide stiens
mileage expense this is an addition
that's come
in uh from the Department along with
Roman 5 any unexpended funds from for
going that was the
date that's just an account that we have
we may anticipate having some additional
funds left over so we're trying to do it
with no additional cost so
um we just saying those funds would
carry forward um so we had obviously a
lot of conversations last time about
paying mileage and stiens and
reimbursements and things like that um
if the department were to consult with
one of those educational experts we
assume there should be some costs um so
the department was in we we so trying to
not have any sort of associated cost
with this I was trying to find funding
that may be um left over in this bium
that we might have some excess funds
Maybe it might be 20 to $30,000 right
now um it it really depends on like what
you know we have so just trying to find
just various lines of of of funding that
so 11 12 might practice would it help
for fiscal it does it does because
otherwise those funds will lapse so
without that there those funds will
automatic lapse um in two months here
and so
right yes right right and what what is
that account number again um it's it's
our state uh State assessment account
right now so it's currently the funds um
support the different assessment
contracts right
now so that date June 30 2025 is good uh
that's I mean we would need 25 because
that's our current budget right now
that's the line we're trying to tell not
to not
lapse um right right but um you know end
on when this task force actually wraps
up because I think we really do need to
look at the time um that we've
designated here um we may want to add
that till 26th but we would need it
anyways for now to make sure this
existing bium doesn't lapse so should
any unexpended funds for the bium in
account and leave out the date no we
need the date need we need the date okay
okay exactly okay y turn back into a
we were we were looked we did look at
Romans 6 what about AB C and
D um it is in establishing the
performance space the task force may
consider one or more of the following
data
indicators and um what remember that
Litany of indicators which we've seen
before we've taken them all out and just
reference that section of law um well we
also took out you you know using line 13
I'm looking at the draft Yeah using only
the best available account Bill any yeah
that was a typo that was should have
never been they with so that it's good
to get that out yes representative
Bel representative vure had a lot of
questions about that and it should not
have been there it was confusing
resp and at some
point we have a lot of responsibility
here
on so what the the task force would
ultimately do is essentially determine
you know a report that says these are
the recommendations
in order to do anything to move forward
with those recommendations the
department would need legislation and so
the oversight committee that we present
this to would hopefully take that up
into the legislation and that
legislation then would require the
Department of Education to implement the
results of that that legislation so
that's when the department would start
doing that work as soon as we have
are there any other changes which we are
issues we might want to discuss here on
this um yeah on Roman six yeah so so
we're taking out right using only the
best available accountability system
yeah I've got in which shall be based on
data and indicators taking out which are
already provided to the department Andor
performance measures that schools are
already
required um and then leaving in um
provided to the department we'll edit
there under state and federal laws or
other available data is deemed you know
relevant something like that because you
you you may want to consider the task
force may want to
consider that considers some some data
that's now available but currently not
being
collected I think yeah and I think we
talk about writing that maybe I'm going
to pull up what we but I I think we do
want to give I I think well I think we
want the task force to be obviously very
conscious of what the department already
collects what schools are responsible
for providing to the department because
we don't want to add a bunch of
indicators that we either can't collect
or that is going to take a ton of time
and what value is that going to be but I
think we do want to give the um the task
force the flexibility of using an
additional data set that we are maybe
not think and there were a fair number
Fair number of them thrown out last time
in this room of X Y and Z so um I can
draft that to be um to add that
flexibility that would be really but I
mean I think so there right now the
department collects data because it is
required to report that data in the
federal accountability system and so
there's no reason why a similar type so
the state accountability system system
requires us to so we're going to collect
the data required for
that and I think to that you know if the
task force is looking at additional data
to be collecting one of the
responsibilities would be to look at the
feasibility if it's not currently
collected like would there be a cost
associated with that would it be born by
the state or would it be born by local
school districts and what would that
look
like so Kaitlyn so you're going to write
some language for Roman six here I can
and adding in or other relative data Etc
yeah yeah yeah
um see other metrics as determined by
the task force that gives them kind of a
wide
open
leave I mean I think we want the task
force to look what at what
people I think they do yeah yeah and
obviously I think having performance
data right it's performance-based
accountability system we want to look at
performance on the state assessment I
think it makes sense that that's listed
as number one so okay so we're now down
so you're you're providing this
information to the State Board of
Education and the legislative oversight
committee are you expecting any kind of
action from the legislative oversight
committee well yes ultimately we would
need legislation
to yeah to enact the new accountability
system as result as a result of this
task force see it doesn't say that right
now it says t for shall provide a report
of findings and recommendations so the
those recommendations and findings come
legislation and and that's
so and it says to the State Board of
Education is it for
future approval or is it you know or or
is it you're looking for yeah we want to
go forward with this through legislation
that come from the do does it need more
guess I don't can
we we need to tell somebody to write a
bill yeah I don't know but I don't know
how to do that um I don't know ifs has
it but that that's exactly what happens
and I don't know can we force anybody to
write a bill on
something add the word make
recomendations for future legation
CL and would that come from the
oversight committee then so if we're
presenting a report to that legislative
oversight committee would the oversight
committee then take the step to then
create a move forward a bill that would
actually enact the PBS uh see the
legislative oversight committee is
appointed by the speaker and the
president and see what year are we
talking
here will there even be a legislative
you
know yeah well
see the bium ends the you're in right
now it ends so I think I think two
things I I think the September 2025 is
probably too ambitious when we put that
date we're going to have to push that
out unfortunately um the department
would like this work done sooner rather
than later um and when I know when we
started drafting this last summer
September 25 seemed really far away but
now it does not seem that far so I would
push it any further than I wouldn't push
it out any further than November which
would be the date most study committee
reports are for for I think be really
challenging I think we need to push out
a whole another year because I think
when we're talking about I think that
unfortunate that when we're talking
about the nomination process and just
even in this room of who the appropriate
members are I think it's going to take
quite a bit of time to get the the
initial task course
organized um by the time this
legislation passes so assuming that you
all get it done and get through
Committee of conference it gets signed
on the governor's desk it goes 60 days
it goes in place in September we can't
ask schools to start thinking about who
should be on this task force September
and October no superintendent is going
to sign up to do anything on September
or October nor or Nate and I because
we're gonna be so then we're talking
about late fall and so September is is
is too ambitious right right so if you
have November
2025 that that would give the task force
a year I I still think I think we
probably need to push it out for another
about June 30
2025 that's 26 26 ex 26 26 I think
that's probably 26 I think that's that
school year doable yeah I think that's
more doable because you're not going to
get a whole lot of work done by anybody
during July August September right no I
I think June 26 is I think probably is
yeah
okay we still didn't though resolve the
so will the oversight committee I mean
so they bring this report will the
oversight I mean
obvious some of you are here that are on
the oversight committee
what if nobody on the oversight
committee wants to move forward
legislation like what do we do about
that that's question Yeah well yeah I
mean you know anybody can file
legislation yeah somebody could file
legislation to have a pbass that does
something completely different than the
TK Force Rec course so so I think um I
think this is where good intentions
comes in okay that that that I think you
would find good intentions among a
bipartisan group on the oversight
committee to file legislation okay yeah
so I I you know that makes sense yeah
that that that makes sense that makes
sense yeah and we're and but I also I
would also think as we talked about it
on line 24 it says report findings and
make
recommendations I think I think that
putting the word make in there I think
makes it a little stronger as it relates
yeah that that works to me make
recommendations in legislative oversite
commit is going to have y or nay ex yeah
yeah and if you pick you know a elected
official pick a
representative
so it doesn't come to us at the last
moment from the other side the
same
e